IPVA dois mil e vinte e quatro chegando, tá?
No meu caso eu vou pagar quatrocentos reais a menos.
Eu vou mostrar pra vocês como faz essa consulta
de forma antecipada.
É bem simples,
é rápido, fácil.
Salva logo esse vídeo
e compartilha também com os amigos,
com os familiares
pra poder as pessoas se prepararem, né?
Que é mais 1 facada aí na virada do ano,
tá vamo lá que EU vou mostrar pra vocês como faz.
Entra no Google e digita tabela fipe.
Importante,
tá pessoal,
entra no link oficial,
é o que termina, ponto org ponto br,
rola a tela até chegar a parte de consultas.
Aí também é importante
porque você vai ter categorias como carros,
caminhões,
motos, enfim,
escolhe a categoria do seu veículo.
Após isso você precisa mudar o mês e o ano,
tá? Então a gente vai escolher aí setembro
de dois mil e vinte e três,
que é o mês parâmetro pra gerar o valor do IPVA.
Feito isso,
escolhe a marca do veículo,
depois eu acho mais fácil escolher primeiro o ano,
tá que aí você limita o modelo,
escolheu o ano também?
Vamos lá escolher o modelo do carro,
clique em consultar.
Pronto, tá?
Você já tem o valor da tabela fipe do seu carro
em setembro de dois mil e vinte e três.
No meu caso ficou em oitenta e oito mil,
quinhentos e quarenta e um reais.
eu pego esse valor e multiplico por quatro por cento.
Tá vai me dar um IPVA aproximado de três mil,
quinhentos e quarenta e um reais
e sessenta e quatro centavos,
cerca de quatrocentos reais a menos
do que foi cobrado no passado.
Por que que eu multipliquei por quatro por cento?
Porque é a líquida do Rio de Janeiro.
Então vocês precisam também pesquisar no Google
aí qual é a líquida do estado de vocês,
por exemplo,
no Espírito Santo é dois por cento,
se eu não me engano.
Na Bahia acho que é dois e meio.
São Paulo é quatro por cento.
Então se no seu estado for,
por exemplo,
dois por cento,
em vez de multiplicar por quatro por cento,
você vai multiplicar por dois por cento.
Tá? É uma maneira muito bacana
da gente ter um valor muito aproximado
quanto a gente vai pagar de IPVA pro ano que vem. Claro,
também existe alguns estados que tem descontos.
Enfim, é,
tem que levar isso em consideração também.
Beleza? Valeu galera!
Abraço! Tá
fica com Deus,
tchau tchau.